(slow piano music)
- [Narrator] This is Ruby,
a burrowing owl.
These long-legged owls
are found throughout
North and South America.
Due to habitat loss,
their population is declining.
Burrowing owls are medium-sized birds
reaching a height of 10 inches
and weighing up to half a pound.
Brown-colored feathers
with white spots compliment its long legs
and short tail.
They nest underground
in abandoned burrows of prairie dogs
or ground squirrels.
Because of their ground level nesting,
they are more subject to predators
than other owl species.
They prefer open grasslands,
but have been know to nest in peculiar
places like golf courses
or airport fields.
But as their habitat continues to shrink,
their population has declined
by a third in the last half century.
This is the burrowing owl.
(slow upbeat music)